recent tensions between china and taiwan
are also having an impact on a somewhat
hidden community
southeast asian migrant workers in
taiwan
according to official records there's
nearly 700 000 of them working on the
self-governing islands they work mostly
in factories and as caregivers but the
uptick intentions across the taiwan
straits has left them worried for their
future in the event of a dangerous
escalation
dw correspondent zachary lee reports
as a migrant worker in taiwan wayu
sabudra works hard to support his family
back home in indonesia
he's never been interested in politics
but the rest intentions between china
and taiwan have started to worry him
my family in indonesia is asking if it's
still safe here and whether there'll be
a conflict
if the worst happens they've asked me to
just come home
and his colleagues now talk about
taiwan-china relations every day
after spending over seven years in
taiwan he could never have imagined
needing to plan a world time evacuation
i'm worried about a war here
especially since the us did not
intervene in the war in ukraine
for now i don't think the possibility of
war is very high
but i haven't heard of any evacuation
plan either
taiwan has nearly 700 000 migrant
workers mostly from vietnam indonesia
and the philippines more than half of
them working in manufacturing factories
others working as caregivers or nannies
gilda banungan is one of them she left
the philippines to come to taiwan in
2015
and now works as a domestic helper
banungan also chairs a migrant workers
union and has found that worries about a
possible taiwan conflict are widespread
in the filipino community here
it seems like if someday the surprise
for
you know the war
and we don't know where can we go
because
in taiwan
also the problem here is for the
language barrier for the migrants and
the locals so
yeah we cannot guarantee of ourselves
here but we try to
comfort each other that we have to be
prepared pannungan has raided her
passport and personal document in case
of an emergency evacuation
but like
she fervently hopes that the world won't
break out here
hopefully there won't be a conflict and
everyone stays safe right now we work
safely and happily here
most migrant workers prefer to move to
taiwan due to better salaries here
taiwan too depends heavily on them
but sabudra and other workers like him
said that the war would append or other
considerations
and joining me now for more from perth
in australia is radhika binava she's a
doctoral student at the university of
western australia and her research looks
at relations between taiwan and
southeast asian countries miss cabana
welcome your research also looks at
southeast asian migrant workers in
taiwan and in a recent article you were
quoted as saying they are like called
orphans or second-class citizens in
taiwan why do you say that
yeah because
these migrant workers
i usually experience discriminations in
their daily life at the at their
workplace in their when they mingle with
the taiwanese society and some of them
are not covered under the taiwan's labor
standard act
so workers migrant workers working in
the
social welfare industries are mostly not
covered under the taiwan labor standard
act what does that mean means that they
are excluded from excluded from the
benefits of minimum wage
regulated hours holidays entitlement and
also labor insurance with this condition
their their
their position is like a second-class
citizen
in taiwan
right uh do you think that that extends
also to when it comes to taiwan uh
making plans uh
when it
in the in the event of a war with china
china is this large migrant population
being excluded from those plans as well
it could be i so far i haven't heard any
plan or evacuation plan
if
the if this is the situation should this
deteriorated in the taiwan street
first
these workers are not
citizens in taiwan they are not taiwan
and they are not part of taiwan
um
they are migrants so they really depend
on the support or protection given by
their home countries either from
indonesia
philippines
thailand or
vietnam
so when it comes into in a future
conflict in the taiwan strait when it
comes into evacuation plan they will
really depend on their government in
their home countries
how then the governments in jakarta for
example or in manila
protect them
evacuate them from the crisis or from
the potential conflict there's uh so far
of course when it comes to uh evacuation
plan a country will prioritize its
citizen and these workers are not
citizens in taiwan not citizens of
taiwan so they really depend on the
protection
from their own government and their
their government do not have a
diplomatic relations with taiwan when
they don't have diplomatic relations
it will cause a limited engagement it
will cause a limited direct
communication between governments and
when it comes into evacuation plan then
you need a very clear plan on how
very clear plan and communication on how
to evacuate them in which point that
they should go from their place in order
to find a safe place for them
to stay for a while while waiting for
the
uh for the flights for example to come
to save them we'll have to leave it
there for the time being thank you so
much for joining us today rati cavinava
from the university of western australia
thank you so much
you